this is our wire my daughter my daughter
walda my daughter derwa my daughter
waldra my eldest granddaughters Ginia
and Neila Serra and sarra granddaughters
twins you could have had either that
blow through IKEA my granddaughter
Marianne my granddaughter Freya my
granddaughter
well-well-well Dina I'm Mary fine my
fears have come true the Starks have
made you theirs my blood is salt and
iron
if the stark boy sends you to me like a
trained Raven clutching his message the
offer he makes his when I proposed he
heeds your counsel I'd lived with him
hunted with him for to his side he
thinks of me as a brother no not here
not in my hearing you will not name him
brother this son of the man who put your
true brothers to the sword or have you
forgotten your own blood if he would
have become Lord
Talia go on he'll be the end of this
house
I'm took you for a moles town [ __ ] when
I saw he wouldn't make my piece for that
who else would have him do i
overestimated him it was a wildling
[ __ ] that seduced my son
is you getting back at me boy
hmm bringing that to my table are making
me dying with it my father brought in my
wife and gave her to his guards he paid
her with silver for each man how many
[ __ ] command that kind of price he
brought me into the barracks and made me
watch by the end she had so much silver
that the coins were slipping through her
fingers and rolling on to the floor I
would have killed the man who did that
to me
wife tell the Lord crow how content we
are this is our place our husband keeps
us safe better to live free than die
slave
don't admit you jealous old man see me
with all these young wives and you with
no one to warm your bed with chose
different paths oh I had you chose the
path with no one but boys on it
you